-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers,
and this is "Late Night."
We hope you're doing well.
And now, if you don't mind,
we're going to get to the news.
Well, after marrying
his cousin,
giving a press conference
at a landscaping company,
and almost masturbating
in the "Borat" movie,
Rudy Giuliani
has finally slipped up.
That's right.
A jury in Washington, D.C.,
last week ordered Rudy Giuliani
to pay nearly $150 million
in the defamation case
brought against him
by two Georgia election workers.
Okay, but he for sure
doesn't have that much money.
You might as well order a dog
to drive you to the airport.
A lot of stress for the dog,
but you're not getting
to the airport.
Russian President Vladimir Putin
was formally nominated
over the weekend
to run in the 2024 presidential
election.
Said Putin,
"If anyone has any questions,
my window is always open.
He's prone to defenestration.
In a new interview, presidential
hopeful Robert F. Kennedy Jr.
says that he thinks people
should be able
to debate the legitimacy
of the election
without being dismissed
as crazy.
Oh, buddy, that's not why
people think you're crazy.
You can debate the election.
What you can't do
is work out in blue jeans.
A Senate staffer was fired
over the weekend
for allegedly filming a sex tape
inside a committee hearing room.
It's the first time
anyone in that room
has ever come together.
Former UN ambassador Nikki Haley
criticized former president
Trump in a new interview
and said that he had
the opportunity
to stop the Capitol attack,
and before that,
he had an opportunity not to
start it.
According to the latest data
released from Pornhub,
the search term "granny"
increased in popularity by 132%
because what better
to hear after
"Who's your Daddy?"
than "I can't remember."
Same dude wrote that
as that "come together" joke.
We should check
his search history.
Or not.
Yeah. Or not.
Officials in New Mexico
have begun testing wastewater
at some high schools
for illicit drugs,
and found that most schools
tested positive for cocaine.
And it has to be
the students,
because there's no way
a teacher can afford cocaine.
Today it was Rolling Stones
guitarist Keith Richards'
80th birthday.
Even crazier, he celebrated by
going to lunch with his parents.
And finally, two seemingly
drunk men in Australia
were arrested after they climbed
into a construction site,
threw bags of concrete off
the scaffolding, fell asleep,
and then refused
to get down for eight hours.
Officials first suspected
they were drunk
when they were Australian.
And that was a monologue,
everybody.
We're up and running.
We got a great show
for you tonight.
You know him from
one of the best shows
of the last few years,
"The Bear."
Currently, he stars
in "The Iron Claw,"
which is in theaters
this weekend.
Jeremy Allen White
is back on the show.
So excited.
And you know her best
from her Emmy-winning role
"on Ted Lasso."
Her special,
"Home for Christmas,"
is on Apple TV+ now.
The great Hannah Waddingham
will also be joining us.
So excited, you guys.
I went to
the Big Apple Circus yesterday
in New York City.
It was amazing.
I'm just being serious here.
I was not looking forward to it.
I had the best time.
My only regret,
should have brought my kids.
I did bring my kids.
It's the best time
I've had with my kids
in like a year.
It was unbelievable.
It's a circus theater, Roncalli.
It's a German outfit.
They're a German circus.
Don't worry about
the language barrier.
I don't know if you've been to
a circus -- almost no talking.
The clowns try to tell you
things,
but it's a lot of like...
I can't -- I know
I'm talking about it.
You might be thinking, "Seth,
we all know circuses are great."
This circus is so [bleep] great.
Juggling.
I don't know why
I've been sleeping on juggling.
When I was seven,
I loved juggling,
and then I started thinking --
I started being snarky
and thinking there were
better things.
Well, let me tell you,
I've spent the last 40 years
looking for something better.
Nothing's better.
And I'll tell you this.
These were a bunch
of German circus people.
Do I think they could do my job?
I know this -- they could do it
better than I could do theirs.
It was so good.
You got to go to the circus,
you guys.
No animals,
which is great.
Not just for the animals,
who I don't think
ever had a lot of fun.
It's no circus for them.
Here's the thing, though.
I'm happy for the animals.
It's doesn't smell terrible.
It used to be you walked
into a circus tent
and you were just met
with a wall of animals.
It was great. Gotta go
to the circus, you guys.
I know I'm talking too much
about the circus,
but it's so good.
And by the way, no animals.
Except then three dudes
come out,
beginning in the second
half of the circus --
By the way, two halves.
My kids don't like
two halves of anything.
During the intermission,
I said to my kids,
"We could go home now."
One of my --
My seven-year-old
looked at me in the eye
and said,
"I don't ever want this to end."
The five year old said,
"I want to join the circus,"
and we let him.
I don't know when I'm going
to see him again,
but if I -- when I do, he's
going to be tightrope walking
and it will have been worth it.
But these three --
second act starts
and it's three guys
in a polar bear suits,
big polar bear suits,
and they walk out.
And it was great
because I knew right away
they weren't real polar bears,
but the suits were good enough
that my kids looked at me
and were like, are those real?
And then I got to look at them
and I was like, no.
And then that's great
because they're like, oh, cool.
Dad knows stuff about bears.
And that for me
is really rewarding
because usually I don't know
[bleep].
Guys, go to the circus.